in deutschland steht eine ganze
industrie kurzform ab nippeln und keiner
kriegt's mit in der windenergiebranche
wurden allein in den letzten zwei jahren
über 26.000 arbeitsplätze gestrichen war
windenergie nicht irgendwie wichtig für
unsere energiewende oder meine ich hätte
das irgendwo gelesen
ja ich glaube doch was ist es gibt aber
auch gar keinen im ersten halbjahr 2009
10 bis ende juni wurden in ganz
deutschland insgesamt wenn ich alles
zusammenzähle 35 neue windräder gebaut
dabei müssten wir um bis 2030 auf die
angepeilten 65 prozent erneuerbare
energie zu kommen jeden tag fünf neue
davon bauen
letzte woche hatte wirtschaftsminister
herr altmaier endlich zum krisengipfel
geladen und das führte leider zu
schlimmen wortspielen der windenergie
geht in deutschland allmählich die puste
aus gut auch in rheinland-pfalz der
ausbau der windenergie flügellahm zu
werden in der wind branche im norden
weht ein laues lüftchen in berlin dann
nur heiße luft
[Applaus]
aber ich habe auch noch eigentlich aber
auch noch ein in der windindustrie
herrscht regelrechte krisenstimmung die
braucht dringend eine organspende
sonst heißt es bald pustekuchen
ja da für mich
ja
übrigens übrigens rausgekommen ist bei
peter lustlos wind gipfel außer
wortspielen original nichts
er bedauert sagte die entwicklung in der
branche und will das thema weiter
diskutieren
toll toll angesichts von 26.000
entlassen was ich super fand war seine
begrüßung weil die begrüßung die passte
einfach fantastisch zum thema
klimaschutz
ich begrüße sie gemeinsam mit meinen
minister kollegen aus den ländern
franz untersteller der weg muss weil
sein flieger erreichen muss das nennt
man wohl subtiles mobbing ja so kommen
wir mal nach woran hakt es denn bei der
deutschen windkraft bei dieser branche
allein 11.000 megawatt hängen gerade im
genehmigungsverfahren fest und dann hat
die groko 2017 ausschreibungen verlangt
das erhöht das finanzielle risiko und
bedeutet in vielen fällen das aus gerade
für kleine windparkbetreiber klar müssen
wir dazu sagen und das ist auch wichtig
unter den leuten die gegen
windkraftanlagen klagen sind auch viele
die sich zu recht sorgen machen wegen
lebensqualität naturschutz oder
grundstückswert aber es gibt eben auch
mehrere sehr dubiose anti windkraft
vereinen ja die haben eine ganz klare
überschneidung mit afd und klimawandel
leuten an und anderen
verschwörungstheoretiker und manche
spots von denen ja sind vielleicht auch
einen tick zu reißerisch in deutschlands
wäldern stern jedes jahr tausende
fledermäuse und vögel
schrecklich da musste der arme
praktikant eine feder ins bild vermeldet
in das gleiche horn trötet übrigens der
vereine vernunft kraft auch da tummeln
sich klimawandel leugner die rätselhafte
weise sogar bei altmaiers wind gipfel in
berlin geladen war und ich sag mal dass
die afg als alte kohle und atom partei
beef mit dem wind hat das war ja eh klar
die von afg sagen windräder während der
vogel killer schlechthin ja und ich
wusste gar nicht dass die afg sich so
für die natur und vor allem für die
vögel einsetzt da sage ich mal route ab
gut ab ausnahmsweise wirklich bis jetzt
nein ganz ernsthaft bis bis jetzt das
sympathischste was ich von dieser partei
gehört habe hier neue spot wir von der
afg lieben unsere natur
doch sie hat einen tödlichen feind
windräder
sie sehen aus wie minarette mit
propeller und wenn man ganz genau
hinhört klingen sie wie ein multi
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit messerscharfen flügel treten sie
millionen unschuldiger arischer vögel
während osteuropäische wölfe einfach
unverletzt unten durch laufen dürfen
danke merkel das einzig positive
sie sind weiß dass trägt denn was die
mainstream-medien uns gerne verschweigen
angetrieben werden windräder oft von
wind aus dem ausland windenergie stoppen
deutsche wind nur noch für deutsche
fahne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ausschließlich
ja finanziert wurde dieser spot von
ihren rundfunkgebühren gern geschehen
die angestellte jede energiegewinnung
das muss man noch mal dazu sagen jede
energiegewinnung hat immer auch
schädliche folgen
wir müssen halt abwägen was am wenigsten
schädlich ist ich sage mal wenn man ein
windrad abbaut am ende dann muss man es
danach nicht für eine million jahre in
der asse lagern
zum beispiel ich begrüße an dieser
stelle dennis knossalla vorsitzender des
anti windkraft vereins aktion sorgenkind
der knossalla was genau wie ihr verein
erreichen es wird sicher überraschen
aber wir möchten diese debatte einfach
mal versachlichen
im namen des gesunden menschenverstandes
endlich auf die fakten kommen und die
faktenlage ist ja klar wen kraft wird
und es wagt was atomkraft diesel und
zwei weltkriege nicht geschafft haben
vollenden jetzt windräder diese killer
sportler aus der hölle ja ein afd man
sagt es noch sachlicher was die groko
will ist doch landwirte und eigenen
angebliche klima schädlinge bestrafen
und noch mehr öko religiöse insekten
massenvernichtungswaffen bauen öko
religiöse insekten
massenvernichtungswaffen
damit werde ich weltmeister beim
scrabble wir dürfen nicht länger
wegschauen herweck 1200 tonnen insekten
und über 100 tausend vögel sterben jedes
jahr am winter hinter mitte durch
geteilt kommt sicher dann doch schon ein
ja aber das will ja nicht sehen
keine frage das ist nicht schön aber nur
mal zum vergleich 18 millionen vögel
sterben bei uns jedes jahr an fenstern
zehn millionen im straßenverkehr nach
der logik müssen sie auch autos
abschaffen oder hochspannungsleitungen
natürlich fallen unsere vögel auch
anderen verbrechen zum opfer
katzen italiener aber das macht die
windräder doch nicht besser
ich sage nur infras ein niederfrequenz
lärm der kreis macht das vibriert bis
runter zum bus lehrmann sich sicherlich
gesunde auch solche vibrationen aber es
gibt weltweit keine einzige valide
studie sie gesund
deutliche schäden im pegel bereich von
windrädern belegt falsch ein
wissenschaftler aus den usa hat jetzt
sogar bewiesen dass infraschall krebs
verursacht welcher wissenschaftler der
beste der anteil der erneuerbaren liegt
jetzt schon in deutschland bei 40
prozent wenn wir die windräder wie sie
wollen wieder abbauen wo kommt denn dann
der strom her ist der steckdose keine
ahnung von irgendwas umweltfreundlich im
atomkraft fracking jedenfalls nicht von
diesen mörder maschinen liebe zuschauer
unterstützen sie die aktion sorgen wird
kaufen sie unsere cd die fidelen
windbeutel mit den 100 schönsten anti
windkraft chansons wie
als biene maja stand
und allen grünen lachten oder in
vorschreibt ist die nacht hat mein hirn
zu brei gemacht
in spa schalter um und bringt uns alle
langsam und dann sind ich noch in der
rolle eines bösen windpark betreibers
so ist tot
[Musik]
für mich nicht denn das kloster michael
beschreibt auf facebook wilke du bist
der letzte arsch nur große fresse ich
möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart auf
hart kommt dann schaust du dir in die
hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt man
trifft sich immer zweimal im leben mach
weiter so mit einer großen fresse wie
können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren